Smouse ago resumes periodic back welcome
back to some more dreadout baby let's
keep playing
oh oh god what the [ __ ] what is that
what is that [ __ ] sound Sophie okay
oh what the piggy oh dear don't worry
piggy
what are you beautiful okay you main you
groan fight man okay you're so fine let
me just touch this okay and go jump luck
oh my god what the [ __ ] it's not gonna
oh he's got it he's got a big out
thought you would call me what the [ __ ]
hahaha oh my god what is happening what
the actual [ __ ] is happening you a whole
oh my god I made it I laughing but for
what brace alright he can't see me now
Kenny where is he where did piggy go
piggy okay alright let's just sneak up
on him
where is he is he there it's hope Doric
like it's so hard to see I guess I don't
need no job lovicott sexy drab whole dad
[ __ ] ass thumbnail did I get the kids
or wife
the door is locked where is he going
like what and what is it pig doing here
anyway
oh god oh god that ass got asked that
ice nice that ice that ice
luckily he's slower than your mom's
titties [ __ ] me [ __ ] him seriously [ __ ]
that guy
all right she's not even freaking out
she isn't good I got that sound [ __ ]
that sound where's this hole it has to
be another way
Oh God nope I'm good thank you very much
no more coffee for me thank you
makes me poop like a mouse okay well I
guess we have no other choice
and can follow this majestic beasts
[ __ ] because everything else is shut
I guess we just have to be careful and
not making a caucus
Oh or we could just go in here and [ __ ]
all we want thank you game three tips
one okay
daftar Pike's inside like [ __ ] please
in Indonesian oh we didn't get much from
this place she really doesn't know where
to point that flashlight it's really
hard to control cuz she's like not
really following perfectly oh well I
guess that's part of the gimmick [ __ ]
you door and that open doing alright I
don't see him oh god I hear him though
easy now I don't want to get followed by
him again is this [ __ ] alright let's
just hope we don't run into his sexy ass
that's a sentence I would never usually
say unless it's a horror game oh god
what is this haha go gentle on me please
hi oh they have nice toilets in this
place
wow I'm lucky I am very lucky good thing
I don't have to poop now wait I lied
sorry okay Oliver fine there oh [ __ ]
what was i let's turn that off for now
actually never mind is this the boys
pooper that sounded wrong
oh god that [ __ ] whispering man I'm
not a big fan of a piggy hey Peggy
oh god what have I done oh you can't go
stairs can you [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] okay we're fine we're totally
fine
this place is fantastic love this place
wow so much Wow God again I got goose
pimples
okay goose oh that's nice
I found a Jenga lot this object is flow
with mystical energy I love Jenkins I
like Pokemon job don't like them don't
like Jiang lot never liked a Jiang lot
in my life never in my life I am Brad
jank loud racist yep I don't know what
that means
okay so don't take it seriously god
dammit Jiang like you were my only
friend Jiang lot why Janet why did you
do this to me
alright we better just check everything
nice couch no it's very comfortable I
guess we should be looking for our
friends but I [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm right
is this work I did boy oh god I don't
like this okay so we're back here now
for some [ __ ]
it's stories now unlocked okay cool we
are back there that's the lobby where we
came from
shortcuts [ __ ] right here
someone's snorting it sounded like
someone's swing let's check all the room
the hint said is that a 10-watt gotta
catch a mouse gigolo - Jenga it's like a
mixture of dildos and pokemons jangle on
let it make sense okay I know for sure
I'm not gonna dad go down there cuz [ __ ]
that
alright maybe the pig is got just maybe
exit aha nice father father father I
forgot it oh god what the [ __ ] where is
he
I can't even see oh god he's guarding
he's guarding he's guarding oh god that
scared me so much what the [ __ ] are you
sound fake easy peasy lemon titty lemon
titty in my shitty shitty pitty lady
MIDI Metamora matter matter matter but I
really want to wear those shoes don't
like god dammit god dammit god dammit
dad did not go as planned it named
selfie cam it okay it's out no more
selfies
no more selfies [ __ ] maybe we just have
to [ __ ] run to the other side of the
corridor I don't know oh god what is
that
the breeze nope ever [ __ ] [ __ ]
open Oh what the [ __ ]
we're just hello hello let's be friends
you know what I love breathing - we have
something in common
took your picture baby or she's not
actually there I only see her in the
camera oh god you're gonna look so good
I gotta Photoshop these pictures and you
still got a lock on a [ __ ] now I'm
gonna take all your picture no Connie me
Oh high five
ha ha how is she what what a dud oh you
ain't that on [ __ ] you ain't that hot
Bates
so many pictures what you gonna do about
it son Oh God
stop stop you ain't no Beyonce [ __ ] Oh
shoe strings shoe strings shoe strength
I don't know why I'm running
you know I'd [ __ ] you [ __ ] yellow and
polos Pogo what that thought oh I don't
like you
I don't like anyone why don't you love
it oh wait cuz I ain't gotta say it one
more time okay one more time oh god I
thought it actually worked [ __ ] me that
[ __ ] ball hey goddamnit I can't
handle this [ __ ] enough and now I had
enough I want to go home I don't want to
go home to mama okay
ah leave me the [ __ ] alone God get a
life [ __ ] ass Jesus pieces prize that
Abita I am going in here and I bet it
will be a wonderful time
Oh semadar the saran castle cap upon my
side my local high school was taken by
surprise yesterday as the whole class
ever stood and suddenly entered a state
of trance I do that [ __ ] to a 10 a.m. as
miss Astrid asked miss Astrid that's
great
was teaching biography to our class a
few students screamed and kicked at
their desk
a minute later every student in class
was screaming and acting erratically she
called for help immediately after they
began speaking in tongues the school
headmaster have announced that incident
was in fact a mass possession of
students really really headmaster you
make up a lie
you be like bay heightens the kids these
days they do the drugs in namely that's
a better explanation the whole anyway
the whole class of 2a was horrified
taken to the nearest it was hurry
hurriedly sorry take the nearest public
infirmary did for treatment a local
medical team treated as soon as well a
professional witch doctor the [ __ ] is
that performed an exorcism eyewitnesses
said that the students regain
consciousness simultaneously at 3 p.m.
that's my favorite hour I got an
achievement for reading that [ __ ] now
I'm gonna go out of this [ __ ] alright
the [ __ ] isn't as forth anymore so
that's a plus ain't gonna play oh god oh
god oh god not this [ __ ] again please
please
oh god it's you as pick a [ __ ] a [ __ ] oh
I love oatmeal toad man oh God
all right fantastic it's great yes
[ __ ] great I don't like her I don't
like the football I don't like how my
pants are wet right now let's go in here
again Jimmy yeah tried twice me that
work oh that sounds great in there let's
never ever go there god damn well what
the [ __ ] are you cat hashtag cute
hashtag funny
hashtag Lowell best achievement ever I
wish you could see them they don't
appear when I record for some reason but
it's really funny I love them
achievements is the only thing I got
going for me right now except really
shitty toilets which I don't think it's
a plus
pensee you asked a suppose but hey what
are you gonna do about it
okay no no you don't do that that [ __ ]
ha ha ha me ma'am holy [ __ ]
nope oh my god I don't want this selfie
oh you get yourself a [ __ ] [ __ ] me I
don't know what the no okay all right
she can't find me in here
I'm twenty nine million percent sure of
not picture oh oh you like that you
selfie [ __ ] oh you ugly ass titties are
gonna be everywhere where's she what the
[ __ ] is she okay
oh you argue that [ __ ] ho you look
skank right should i stunk it ok she's
done no she's not behind me [ __ ]
[ __ ] went behind me that call my
ghost of PDA was updated alright great
times
hmm some dance would be great right name
oh god this is not easy to play man this
is really hard to play Oh God
well at least I know she can be defeated
but that was not easy man I thought I
was a goner I thought I was a good e
what I find Oh God
sorry I clicked it away really quick
well it was probably Oh goddamn it no
not just [ __ ] again where is she
is it working cuz I sure [ __ ] hope it
is oh god it's too picky so I can a game
that i'ma tell me about the camera
oh god I'm losing batteries with the
money what is that what was that
my father
oh hello all right breasts I'm gonna
have to end this episode here hope you
enjoyed watching you better leave a like
the saying let the sky come bro today
and I'll see you next episode breath
love you